last week you may recall stanley tucci
when absolutely viral this was
everywhere because he showed everyone
how to make a Negroni from his kitchen
people love this here's a quick look at
that piece of tape you can do it on the
rocks okay well that's very impressive
but I was thinking what about those
people out there that have run out of
all the main ingredients you'd use for a
cocktail and they need to know how to
make a drink using what's left
during quarantine well I knew who to go
to for this Andy take it away
today I'm gonna teach you how to make
great cocktails with whatever you've got
on hand this one is a fun one with kind
of a summery feel it's called who peed
in the pool first and we start with some
Blue Curacao pour that out see look so
man nice and blue just like a swimming
pool then you pour some grenadine in it
and it's gonna stain it like people who
have those chemicals in the pool like if
you pee it in and turns it red oh no
someone peed in the pool mixup is what I
like to call a Staten Island iced tea
it's basically just a regular iced tea
and then I just crush up some of my
Staten pills in it this next one's
called the pacemaker take some vanilla
extract
it's got liquor in it and almond milk
one to Roseate to taste then you garnish
with a pickle from a jar that you forgot
you had why did they call it two-faced
maker cuz of this oh my god oh this next
drink is called you're up Pisco remember
that bottle of pisco that a friend
bought you back in 2008 after they went
to Peru well it's time to break that
sucker up
what is that this next one's called The
Sopranos finale just pour a little bit
of whatever we've got left in the
cabinet empty out all those old bottles
into a shaker give it a shake and then
while you're listening to journey's
don't stop believin take a big old go
[Music]
this next one is called down the hatch
what you need to do is find that bottle
of fairnie Branca that somebody brought
to a party and then pour that [ __ ] right
down the sink I'm not gonna drink it
that's it
happy bartending everybody
thanks Andy and just a reminder don't
take any of Andy's advice because it
could kill you